mr speaker i'm so grateful for the
resolve that people have shown
throughout the crisis
thanks to this shared sacrifice we've
been able to announce
that we will not be renewing our
national restrictions in england
and we've been able to announce uk wide
arrangements for christmas
allowing friends and loved ones to
reunite and form a
five-day christmas bubble and i know
that this news provides hope for so many
but we must remain vigilant
there are still today 16
570 people in hospital with coronavirus
across the uk
and 696 deaths were reported
yesterday that means 696
more families mourning the loss of a
loved one
and the house mourns with them so as
tempting as it may be we cannot simply
flick a switch and try to return life
straight back to normal
because if we did this we would undo the
hard work of so many
and see the nhs overwhelmed with all
that that would entail
we must keep suppressing the virus
while supporting education the economy
and of course the nhs
until a vaccine can make us safe that is
our plan we will do this by returning to
a tiered approach
applying the toughest measures to the
parts of the country where cases and
pressure on the nhs
are highest and allowing greater freedom
in areas where prevalence is lower
while the strategy remains the same the
current epidemiological evidence
and clinical advice shows that we must
make the tears
tougher than they were before to protect
the nhs through the winter
and avert another national lockdown so
we've looked
at each of the tiers afresh and
strengthened them as the prime minister
set out on
monday in tier one if you can work from
home
you should do so in tier two
alcohol may only be served in
hospitality settings as part of a
substantial
meal and in tier three indoor
entertainment hotels and other
accommodation will have to close
along with all forms of hospitality
except for delivery and takeaway
mr speaker i know that people want
certainty about the rules they need to
follow in their
area these decisions are not easy but
they
are necessary we've listened to local
experts and been guided by the best
public health advice
including from the joint biosecurity
center
we set out the criteria in the covert 19
winter plan
and we published the data on which the
decisions are made
as the winter plan sets out the five
indicators
are the case rate in all age groups in
particular cases amongst the over 60s
the rate at which cases are rising or
falling
the positivity rate and the pressures on
the local nhs
when setting the boundaries for these
tiers we've looked not just at
geographical areas
but the human geographies which
influence how the virus spreads
like travel patterns and the
epidemiological situation in neighboring
areas
while all three tiers are less stringent
than the national
lockdown that we're all living in now to
keep people safe
and to keep the gains that are being
made
more areas than before will be in the
top two
tiers this is necessary to protect our
nhs
and keep the virus under control turning
to the tiers specifically
the lowest case rates are in cornwall
the isle of wight and the isles of silly
which will go into tier one
in all three areas they've had very low
case rates throughout and i want to
thank residents for being so
vigilant during the whole pandemic i
know that many other areas would want to
be
in tier 1. i understand that my own
constituency of west suffolk has the
lowest
case rate for over 60s in the whole
country and i want to thank matthew
hicks
and john griffis the leaders of suffolk
and west suffolk councils
and their teams for this achievement but
despite this and despite the fact
suffolk overall has the lowest case rate
outside
of cornwall and the isle of wight our
judgment
looking at all of the indicators and
based on the public health advice
is that suffolk needs to be in tier two
to get the virus further under control
now i hope that suffolk and so many
other parts of the country can get to
tier 1
soon and the more people stick to the
rules the quicker that will happen
we must make the right judgments guided
by the science
the majority of england will be in tier
two
but in a significant number of areas i'm
afraid
they need to be in tier three to bring
case rates down
now i know how tough this is both for
areas that have been in restrictions for
a long time
like leicester and greater manchester
and also for areas where cases have
risen sharply recently
like bristol the west midlands and kent
the full allocations have been published
this morning and laid as a written
ministerial statement just before this
statement began
i understand the impact that these
measures will have
but they are necessary given the scale
of the threat that we face
we'll review the measures in a fortnight
and keep them regularly under review
after that
i want to thank everybody who's in the
tier three areas for the sacrifices that
they're making
not just to protect themselves and their
families but their whole community
and regardless of your tier i ask
everyone
we must all think of our own
responsibilities to keep the virus under
control
we should see these restrictions not as
a boundary to push
but as a limit on what the public health
advice says we can safely do
in any area but frankly the less
any one person passes on the disease the
faster we can get
this disease under control together and
that is on all of us